DALE MARKOWITZ: All right,
we are 15 minutes in.
And-- oh, it doesn't look that
compelling, I'll be honest.
It's the holidays.
And there is nothing
that that makes
me want to do more
than machine learning.
Today I'm going to build a
machine learning model that
will analyze recipes and then
dream up an entirely new recipe
that I'll bake and eat
right before you here today.
And to make the project
a little bit sweeter,
I'll add just a sprinkle
of model explainability
so that we understand
why our model is making
the predictions that it is.
I'll be joined by Sara Robinson.
Sara is an AI expert and
baking extraordinaire
who works with me at Google.
Hey, Sara.
SARA ROBINSON: Hey, Dale.
Thanks for having me.
DALE MARKOWITZ: I heard
that a couple of months
ago you use a machine
learning model
to come up with a new
recipe that you baked.
Can you tell me about that?
SARA ROBINSON: So
I've been baking
a ton over the past few months.
And after following
a lot of recipes,
I started to notice that
a lot of baking recipes
follow a pattern.
So I started to wonder,
since machine learning
is all about finding
patterns in data,
could I build a
machine learning model
to predict what
I'm baking, given
a list of ingredient amounts?
So I built a model to
predict whether a recipe was
a bread, a cake, or a cookie.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So we're going
to do exactly the same thing
here today.
We'll build a model that
takes a list of ingredients
and then predicts
bread, cake, or cookie.
And then we're going
to use that core model
to come up with new recipes
that we'll bake, right?
SARA ROBINSON: Awesome.
Let's get started.
So step one is to collect a data
set of cookies, cake, and bread
recipes.
We gathered about 700 recipes.
Next we had to do a bit
of data pre-processing.
For example, there's
a lot of consensus
that banana bread and pumpkin
bread are actually cakes.
Even Paul Hollywood agrees.
So we had to move the
banana and pumpkin
breads from the bread category
into the cake category.
DALE MARKOWITZ: Next, we
slimmed down the recipes
to just their core ingredients,
like flour, eggs, butter,
sugar, and a couple more.
SARA ROBINSON: We also converted
all of our ingredient amounts
from cups and sticks and
teaspoons and tablespoons
into one single
measurement unit.
We used ounces.
OK, so here are
all of my recipes.
They're converted into
ounces, and cleaned up
and labeled in a Google Sheet.
To build my model, I'm
going to use a tool
in Google Cloud called
AutoML Tables, which
is a no-code tool for building
machine learning models
to analyze tabular data, like
spreadsheets or databases.
OK, I'm opening up
Tables, and I'll
import my data from that
CSV I just showed you.
I have to select
the bucket where
I want the data to be stored.
And it'll take a
second to import.
When it's done, I can
click on my new data set.
And as you can see, a couple
of stats about the data
are automatically generated,
like whether certain columns
are missing values, and also
this useful field, Correlation
With Target, which
says in isolation
how good is each
of these columns
at predicting whether or not
something is cake, bread,
or cookie.
I've also selected
a target field,
which is what we're
trying to predict,
which is, in this case, Type,
that I've already selected.
To train a model, I'll click
the Train Model button,
name my model, say how long
I want it to train for,
specify which columns
I want to include.
I don't want to use the name
of the recipe or URLs or IDs
or anything like that.
And then I click
Train Model and wait.
This part could take
a couple of hours.
When my model is
done training, I
can see how well it did
in the Evaluate Model tab.
Here I can see lots of
stats on model accuracy.
And if I scroll down to
the Confusion Matrix,
I can also see how
often my model correctly
predicted recipes.
So it was most
accurate for bread,
which it labeled
correctly 93% of the time,
and a little less accurate
for cookies, which it confused
for cake 21% of the time.
When I'm ready to use my
model, I can hop into the Test
and Use tab.
And here I can make predictions
right from within the UI.
So I can fill in the values for
a cake recipe, click Predict,
and boom.
The model thinks this is
cake, which is correct.
DALE MARKOWITZ: So
Sara was able to build
a model that takes the recipe
and then predicts cookie, cake,
or bread.
But the inquisitive
baker might want
to know, what is it that
makes a cookie a cookie?
What gives it that
chewy-crunchy property,
that cookieness, if you will?
And what makes bread
fluffy and cake spongy?
In other words, we want to
model that not just made
a prediction, but
also explains what
ingredients it was looking at
when it made that prediction.
And that's called
model explainability.
SARA ROBINSON: Right.
We want to understand how
important each ingredient is
to the model when it's
deciding whether something is
a bread, a cookie, or a cake.
I can take a look at Feature
Importance, which tells me
how important different
ingredients are
to the overall
model's predictions.
So in this case,
butter, sugar, and yeast
were really good at helping
differentiate the baked goods.
Now, even though butter might be
important to the overall model,
it might be that different
ingredients matter more
depending on the recipe.
So if I go into the
Test and Use tab,
I'm going to put
in a cake recipe.
And then I'll hit this Generate
Feature Importance box,
hit Predict.
And then I'll be able
to see how ingredients
matter for a specific recipe.
Here egg and fat got the highest
feature importance scores,
so we can assume that they're
the most important thing
the model is looking at when it
decided that this was a cake.
DALE MARKOWITZ: OK,
so now I'm going
to try something really radical.
I'm going to bake not a
cookie or cake, but something
that our model deems to be
a split between the two,
a "cakie," if you will.
SARA ROBINSON: And I'm going
to bake something that's
a half bread, half cookie.
I'm going to call
it a "breakie."
To find a breakie recipe,
I adjusted the ingredients
in the model UI until
our model predicted
that our recipe was about
equal parts cookie and bread.
Same for Dale's cakie.
DALE MARKOWITZ: All right,
Sara, you ready to bake?
SARA ROBINSON: Yes.
Let's do it.
On your marks, get set, bake.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DALE MARKOWITZ: None of my
training prepared me for this.
Um.
All right, here's the cakie.
Good luck, little cake--
cookie.
Cakie.
SARA ROBINSON: Here
is what we've got.
DALE MARKOWITZ: OK.
I guess I'll try to
pry it from the pan.
SARA ROBINSON: It does
taste like a cookie,
but it is a little
bit more airy.
DALE MARKOWITZ: I can't tell
if it's cooked all the way.
SARA ROBINSON: [LAUGHING]
[THUMPING]
DALE MARKOWITZ: Did not
work exactly the way
I had hoped it might work.
SARA ROBINSON: This is
actually pretty good.
[TRUMPET FANFARE]
DALE MARKOWITZ: OK,
it's kind of nasty.
SARA ROBINSON: So, yeah,
I guess it's a success.
DALE MARKOWITZ: I wonder if I
put the right amount of flour
or double the amount of flour.
So I feel I kind of flubbed
that recipe, something
with the flour.
But Sara then went back
and baked it herself,
and her cakie came
out just fine.
So I guess we'll have to
attribute that to human error.
If you want to know the
details of this project
and steal our recipes,
make sure you check out
the blog post linked below.
Happy holidays, and
see you next year.